I'm not going to tell you that our next
presenter has written plays novels
essays stories histories that he's won a
National Book Award and a Pulitzer Prize
because you know that all I'll simply
say is to quote Carlisle who said fame
is an accident that is sometimes
accompanied by talent
here's Norman Mailer
there's a marvelous story told about
Voltaire it seems that he wants for the
first time in his life that rather an
advanced age went to a male bordello
that is a bordello for homosexuals and
on the next day one of his friends said
what did you think of the experience and
he said it was interesting did you like
it yes rather I rather liked it
will you go again and Voltaire said no
once a philosopher twice a pervert it
occurred to me that that is the role of
the screenwriter
he he writes his words and they have a
life and then the director comes along
and gives it another line that's a
perverted life it takes immense
character and exceptional talent to be a
good screenwriter I suspect this
possibly more difficult to be a great
screenwriter than a great novelist or a
great playwright and so I come here
tonight prepare to give this award with
no rancor and some real respect the
nominees for the best original
screenplay this year are one our John
Charles - Keller and Daniel Thompson for
kuzhi kuzhi n-- water Bernstein for the
front paddy Chayefsky for Network
Sylvester Stallone for Rocky
and leaner vet molar for seven beauties
the winner is paddy Chayefsky for
network
the name the Warlocks pervert
I don't as a rule in fact I don't ever
before remember making public
acknowledgement of private and very
personal feelings but I think it's time
that I acknowledge two people whom I can
never really thank properly or enough I
would like to thank my wife Sue and my
son dan for their indestructible support
and enthusiasm for their ideas their
discussions their stimulation and for
their very presence my gratitude and my
love thank